so I'm just conference like most of it
things that are being done or like very
far away from real life because in every
lie if you don't have like examples and
answers right it doesn't work like that
in real life maybe life you take
decisions and you get some rewards in
the future are much later you go to
university and you have first money
because you went to university much much
later so and like this big it's like
climbing the stairs and hopefully up
there there is a reward but it can't
know if it was going to beat her or not
so small pig has a job that helps him to
helps her to persevere and actually go
up he climb so this is pretty much what
the reinforcement learning is about and
this is what I'm gonna attack you I'm
gonna like show you certain so I'm
Matthew I deal with deep learning rate
forces learning and is exactly what this
talk gonna be about I had privileged to
work with a couple companies including
Berlin companies lately but yeah let's
go straight to the topic so what can you
do with with reinforcement learning
let's see a couple of examples let's
start with funny ones so this is for
example a robot taught with resources
learning to play table tennis well it
doesn't do like a great job it wouldn't
win with a master of table tennis but
still it's loaded a reasonable strategy
right especially if you take into
account that the only input for learning
here is our video so it actually did the
arm here records the video and it
responds asynchronously to you to the
input oh now next example stop it so are
you might have heard about alpha go
armed
a google deepmind one with master of God
520 using exactly well one part of the
solution was reinforced it learning it
put it all together with like supervised
learning and bunch of other stuff really
crazy thing Oh another thing you can do
and this is actually my favorite one so
far is for example it is creating like
finding objects on an image so what you
would usually what people would usually
do is so they would use simple neural
networks for for doing that there's a
couple of problems with that one is that
it takes a lot of time because the
neural network needs to look like at
each say part of the image like pretty
much sequentially to figure out is there
the object they or not and you know into
stride for pull out like a couple of
pixels at a time so it takes a lot of
computer problems actually do this so as
you can do instead is to create a game
out of this problem and the game is you
can zoom in like here that you can zoom
in the image you can move the image
right or left you can zoom out the image
you can move the image we can move the
bounding box up or down and and you can
stretch the image you can stretch the
bounding box and each time you're doing
this move you're getting some reward and
every word is roughly the distance from
the true bounding box for this curve in
our case and it turns out that this
approach is actually not only faster
than traditional approaches but it's
only but it's also more robust it simply
works better um and what i did i play
with concept and I reimplemented and the
original paper that introduced typical
lighting and and I started to play space
invaders and that'sthat's that's how it
goes so you can see it's not like
extremely good but if you think about
like the input of this the input for the
algorithm is exactly is the screen
frames there is and and the only thing
that the guy can do to take actions so
so the actions the the guy is doing here
is go left go right or should or did
that thing and so it knows nothing it
actually I never told him that this
button moves the shape to the left or
this button moves the ship to the right
I never gave him any clues about what
the game is about it actually the only
thing that that he gets as an input
apart from the frames is the score so it
actually can see that some actions
brought him like additional words now
this is how how how the training
progresses so you can see that after 108
box which in my case is about five
million actions taken by the bilingual
network it achieves like pretty
reasonable result and and then it kind
of lightens out but it keeps loading
anyway and this is how this like
distribution of the of the game rewards
the funny thing here if you're
interested why why it keeps like why
it's so dense here that's because it's
like the end of the game so like 600
points is pretty much the point where he
reaches the next level so he's very good
at getting there and since this since
the spaceship start moving faster than I
know it's not so good at like jumping
over this level and like you can do
something like that to this actually do
and this is exactly the same algorithm
like pretty much not a single line of
code change I mean nothing really
nothing pretty good you can see how good
it is at aiming it's that and the
strategy is reasonable give sterling 430
laughs that's what you would do anyway
right because it mean in this scenario
you can only turn left to right and
shoot
so serve the best strategy is to keep
keep moving into the right direction
right the same direction oh my god at
this but this this is fun because here
you can see what what the agent actually
sees so he doesn't see the color of
colors friends just gray scale and then
scaled back to like 80 x 80 pixels and
in this scenario the goal is to avoid
the the fireballs should it should
really get at at the agent and he is
extremely good at that like he really
does a good job okay I could show me
more of that but maybe let's go straight
to the point so how does it work so as I
mentioned earlier it's all about the
rewards I'm not actual I know at truth
because there is no truth in our world
we have know whether this move is like
the best move or not it's how to say
it's very hard to implement artificial
intelligence playing space invaders that
would be as good as that based on the
input only um so haven't work so first
of all we have a world and in our case
we have an emulator of the space
invaders and this emulator once we give
him give her the frame I mean once we
give her at the action for a given frame
I like so we are in this state we that's
what we see basically then we take an
action and the emulator gives back new
state so the new frame and the number of
points that we got on by taking this
action and the information whether we
whether we lost a life or not now what
we could do with it is yes so it's
simply imagine that our goal is actually
to create a policy a strategy that given
a frame we want to take an action so for
example
given and yes oh how to do that so so
there is a sconce of q-learning inside
of like part of reinforces learning is
all about q-learning and very briefly
about that so so we want to construct a
function that given a state network is
frame will end like any of the actions
that I can take will give us an estimate
of how good this action is once we have
that but what does good actually mean
that's like that's very well specified I
know it will get there but given that we
can very simply implement a policy
because all it takes is actually taking
saying that we want to take the action
that gives us the biggest Q value um
yeah so let's do it like this oh so we
can think about so like including the
our goal is really to accumulate as many
rewards until the termination of the
game as possible right that's the goal
in our lives pretty much as well more or
less so where we are we keep taking
reactions we keep getting the rewards
and we would love to define the queue as
this equation the problem is we don't
know what the future gonna give us right
we don't know what's going to happen in
the future so we don't know what the
reward is going to be in the future but
we have a nice inside here which says
basically that are they this expression
in the brackets is nothing else but the
Q function but in a new state right so
how does it work so we are in a state we
are we're living in a state right now
and we wonder what's going to be what's
going to happen how to put in words yeah
so we're at this stage we take an action
we have an estimate of what's gonna how
many points we're going to gather
throughout the game then we take an
action and we are new state and we can
ask the same question so how many points
and I cannot get until the end of the
game now if these estimates differ I
mean this estimate will differ but if
this estimates differ a lot then we
would say hey we are surprised right we
asked we expected that by taking this
action i will get this match award i
took the action and now it seems that
I'm can I get less or more and this is
important this is like this notion of
surprise is very natural because that's
what happens the real life right you
cross the work across the crossroad and
if a car hits you that is like oh yeah
ah next time I will think more carefully
before crossing the road right and
that's exactly what's happening here so
how to how to put in math back again so
we said that in the in like the ideal
world we would have an equation like
that that's what I described I'm going
to go but we don't have that we need to
get there so how to get there so we want
to have an estimate of Q i will call it
Q hat and Q hat is supposed to be an
estimate and now we define the surprise
is exactly what I told you now why is it
so important you have this surprise
because this surprise you will still see
it in a second will help us define loss
function for our neural network let's
get there so your guys work as you know
is basically a very complex function
it's nothing more it just takes an input
gives it output it's very complex and we
know how to teach it in our case in my
case it's a couple of convolutional
layers and too dense layers the
important thing is that the output or a
neural network is supposed to be the
values of the Q function so the
estimates of how good this move is going
to be
yeah and the surprise that we define a
second ago it's exactly the loss
functions we're going to use now the
funny thing here is that a supervised
learning setup what you have is x and
y's and your loss function is a function
of X's and Y's here the loss function
keeps changing because the last function
is defined in terms of of the q of the
queue in a twisted way we have Q here
twice we have the output network like
done is slightly twisted way but but it
works anyway yeah there is still a
couple of problems if you want to play
if you want to play space invaders or
any other games because a single frame
is not enough to actually understand
what's going on you don't know if this
laser beam here goes up or down which
might be actually crucial information
right so what you do instead is you put
a couple of frames so you want to input
a couple of frames instead of single
frame now so usually so if you know
networks you have this tensor stuff all
of inputs right so your input this
usually like four dimensional sensor and
the second dimension is usually used for
RGB channels so instead here we are
using this channels for this tag a
couple of frames one on top of the other
so the unilateral has access to
information not only not not only the
current frame but also three previous
frames and this helps a lot this
actually makes the neural network learn
much faster and much better
there's a couple of a live details that
they are funny so when you teach a
neural network and you're using SGD
stochastic gradient descent then one of
the most important things is that you
keep the the mini batches d correlated
otherwise as GG is not going to work
it's going to yeah converge something
weird so it means that we can't really
use last-32 experiences to feed into the
neural network so back in 93 someone
came up with the idea that instead we're
going to keep the experiences in memory
and the back propagation step will not
be based on like the last 32 frames so
seen but will be sampled from the memory
so we sampled experiences from memory we
put it through the network and then we
do backdrop and that's how we learn also
important thing is exploration the rate
for learning is a lot about exploration
exploitation that dilemma are in order
to to be able to exploit the world you
need to explore first long enough right
that's what children do they keep
running around and exploring and it
might be overwhelming how to exploit
world but that's the only way for them
to learn now after some time of
exploration we want to start exploiting
the strategies that we learned because
after all we are here to gather as many
words as possible so in this case the
exploration is very simple we just flip
a coin at each step at each before
taking action we just flip a coin and we
decided okay are we going to explore or
we can i exploit if we decided we
explore then we flip a coin again and
which is the action that we take this
exploration this epsilon
words the probability of off of like you
know coin flip and and of course it
decays to some all point one or
something okay that's I'm not gonna
speak about other heels now my
implementation is actually available out
there you can grab it you can run it for
a couple of days before something useful
comes up good luck so I didn t on less
than I didn't I ews on spotting
instances because I cheap yeah and like
I right here like it takes both 36 hours
of training to be able to say okay it
does a good job or okay it's really
crappy it took me about 40 rounds to
achieve those 1,000 points press hold
pretty much because I kept improving
things and there are there's lots of
tiny details that if you omit or if you
don't realize that the existent thanks
are gonna perform worse than then expect
it um yeah that's so basically it oh I
was so fast I can show you I can show
you the other doom games it's gonna be
interested right yeah so this is for
example a scenario of when you are need
to gather gallery um medicates there's
the whole point of this thing and it
does pretty much a good job like when it
sees the corner it keeps going left to
actually turn around wait which is which
is pretty crazy actually and then you
know just keep going it's awesome
and this one this one is also fine and
I'm sure we're gonna see something here
but here on the left there is a guy and
the goal is to shoot him now obviously
we don't see him very well but actually
the neural latour does so and it does
pretty good job so it's hard for us to
judge how good job it does but it yeah
maybe you can actually yeah okay going
back to the thank you page thank you
it's your hand if you have a question
here we have thank you for an
interesting talk I've only played around
with cooling a little bit and the one
thing that I've had a problem with is
that I needed to tell it for every state
I'd have every possible action it can
take and then how much you would it will
get and that gets very complicated very
fast maybe I didn't they did something
wrong but how do you actually estimate
the reward for an action if you don't
really know what it's going to be yeah I
mean in this case we simply take a look
at what this core with the actual score
is and what this car is in previous step
and we take you know a difference and
that the reward for this action but what
I don't understand is how you want to
know before taking actually what's the
best action yeah okay I see what I see
what you mean so it's it's all about
this like the estimate so did the neural
network is supposed to estimate the is
this ideal Q function and
I don't know and that's it no I'm sorry
I'm sorry it's just it's it's fuzzy it's
not that easy to explain so Q function
it so if you if you imagine the Q
function by definition is like the
expected accumulated future we were
right then you don't then your question
is has no ground I mean it is it is I
mean if it is and then our estimate is
poor but we still treat it as it was
accurate does the answer your question
yeah I mean it's tricky um it is it
takes a little bit of time of reflection
to actually realize going on hi o
goddess loud I you were talking about
channels before and you said normally
there are there afford the you've
mentioned four dimensions and one of
them was RGB yeah what might the other
channels be or what would the other
channels be yeah yes I don't know so not
so not really you you while you can
think about an image so a black and
white image grayscale image as a two
dimensional thing now color image is the
three-dimensional thing because you have
a three channels red green and blue now
in our case we consider only grayscale
image at the frame we just we just we
just ignore the colors and we make it
gray scale and then we stack our one
frame previous frame previous prime
previous frame right now the first
dimension is the batch dimension so you
just put thirty two of such images are
that's why you have such channels a
height and width that's what you put
into your new network usually
I think um didn't alpha go lose one of
his games or has dreams alfa GO lost ah
well there were actually two matches
with to master goes yeah and the first
one actually alphago one second one
there was four to one but it was with
another go master yeah there was another
question over erica's um yeah thanks for
the interesting talk I was just
wondering why does it help to actually
include in space invaders the three
previous or how many previous frames it
was huh because if you would just model
like if you would just have well the one
basically shot that goes in the other
direction from your defender I don't
know how I would call it sorry I've
never played it it's like if you would
just make it in a different color than
shouldn't like the algorithm figure out
by itself which direction it should be
moving on yeah but we don't want to
change the game in any way we don't want
to modify the game we just want to apply
the algorithm to all the games are out
there uh yeah I yeah I guess I see that
but like if you would have a different
color yeah yeah what do we don't then we
wouldn't need the previous frames yeah
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely the
previous frames is done here it's a
technical trick to make the UM the
neural network aware of like time you
can also use some recurrent neural
networks and that's actually what what
was done and then you can then you can
avoid this trick um but it's faster this
way it's like slow enough this way
anyway thanks a lot what how does it
doesn't model work with the problem that
the reward is actually coming in a lot
of steps later like when you shoot
upwards you hit the whatever the monster
is there
and like ten frames or 20 frames later
yeah that's a very good question
thankfully we have the right slide here
so okay we can actually take a look here
so it's all about you know our ikea
function so take a look here and imagine
if gamma was zero right so you can y0 in
this equation then all we take into
account all we want to consider is the
nearest reword and then we are not going
to learn too much because we're going to
like take actions only to take the
nearest world we are not going to really
think about the future but if gamma
grows and actually like usually people
said cameras like 0 point 99 so it's
like decaying very slowly with time if
you take a look at this equation it
means that they're words that are far
far away in time are considered as a
little bit less important but um but on
the other hand they are there so if i if
i shoot my laser beam right now i will
get some and and the spaceship gets like
gets destroyed in 10 steps in 10 10 10
actions later then i will get for that
government to 10 times the reward so
it's still going to be a pretty huge
word that is dr. your question yeah
thanks for the great talk um how
sensitive is your model actually to the
hyper parameters like gamma epsilon from
your have some ingredients ready gene
yeah so there's just about like 20
parameters I didn't mention most of them
that's a good question um
it is I mean there are some parameters
that are extremely important i would say
that gum ma and the epsilon yeah you
will see difference but it will work
anyway I mean of course if you said
grandma 20 times not going to work but
if you change it but I can't decide well
it would work maybe slightly worse but
it would work now there are some
parameter is usually related to
stochastic gradient descent and here the
stochastic gradient descent was actually
performed using RMS prop so-called keep
my enormous prop very well hidden
algorithm that you can really fine
around but it exists and there for
example changing this by 20 percentages
destroys everything there's a very tiny
island of right convergence of the
neural network if you if you don't put
it right and it's just gonna die very
very quickly but this is a nice thing is
going to de breach extremely quickly
just in a couple of minutes yeah have
you tried setting gamma 2 values greater
than 1 it going to diverge by definition
ah by like in including setup you never
considered gum migrated than one I mean
even one is tricky and you come to use
it always because if you're if you're
game has never terminates then York you
would converge me if anything doesn't
make sense ok this might sound like a
total new question but how did you
actually let this guy play the game all
right did you have a robot hand that
moves the joystick or did you don't know
how to do it so there was actually
there's there's actually environment
created arm cold
I don't remember how it's called anyway
arcade games learning environment were
someone actually took the authority
emulator and and expose an API through
which I could interact with the game
okay and the same the same trick with
doom there is also an IP I created and
you can interact with that you get the
information about how many points you
got etc ok in the second question if I
may what is the most complicated games
somebody has already achieved alpha go I
guess but sorry go go right to the thing
that I feel like you do game oh well we
can have gone through I don't know it's
a it's a funny question I don't know we
played recently with doom that's that's
pretty complex you have 3d world there
are totally new challenges the scenarios
that I showed you here are pretty simple
but if you imagine like a deathmatch
scenario when you have 50 possible
actions if you take into account like
changing weapons etc etc it turns out is
like 50 possible actions and you have
like no there are completely new
problems because you don't see the world
as a whole so here we had like partial
observability but only in terms of time
where as in doom you look at the part of
the world and it's very tiny fraction of
the world so how to handle that that's I
guess not exactly close question yet
thank you
our techniques like this actually used
for BOTS insurance or are you planning
on doing something like that well what
do you mean both at computer plays no I
never heard about it I don't think so
that they should but they could I mean
it would be impossible to win of such
but I mean in space invaders the best
can achieve like 9000 the best
implementations with like a couple of
additional tricks can achieve as much as
nine thousand points which for me
frankly speaking I mean I could I wasn't
able to achieve like 1500 that was
completely beyond my capabilities of
course I'm not an expert right but
generally speaking like this deep
q-learning gets so in most of the Atari
games live like 50 available gets better
than the experts um okay I have a
question what are the advances in some
card games like let's say poker and you
know using the same framework just a
disc or or the function will be
calculated on the let's a monetary value
of your stock let's say hmm hmm good
question now you don't know I don't know
any more questions we still have a
couple of minutes ok so then oh there's
another one
no maybe I can comment on the poker
thing so I I guess it's gonna suck hard
so when you try to solve poker usually
what people do is some game theoretic
approaches like counterfactual regret
minimization where you have a better
model of the game uh and where you can
like converge to the Nash equilibrium
quite fast because I guess usually in
poker the problems the game set is super
big and I don't know here it's still
manageable I guess ah well it differs
how you look at it here it took like the
frame it's 320 x 160 of course we can we
can resize it to 84 x 84 but still
number of states in theory is like 1600
plus the time frames reaches for dates
were so it's 64 6400 like inputs that
approach the convolutional layers
compress it to something like 200
features but i really like don't know
the answer yeah i'm not that good in
poker and maybe i will not just that
okay so thank you matthew very much yeah
i mean
so if you wanted to play with that I
will pass this presentation online I
mean it is already online just posted on
slack for you if you have any questions
feel free and there's lots of good links
here